después de todo el trabajo que hemos
hecho con fluidos a lo mejor tienes una
muy muy buena idea de lo que la presión
es ahora vamos a pensar un poquito de lo
que realmente significa especialmente
cuando pensamos en un gas metido en
algún volumen digamos nada más hay que
recordar la diferencia entre gas y
líquidos los dos son fluidos pero un gas
es compresible mientras que un líquido
es incomprensible verdad así que vamos a
empezar a enfocarnos en los gases
digamos que tenemos un contenedor
este contenedor y que además voy a tener
un montón de gas ahí adentro porque allí
de qué está hecho el gas va no está
hecho realmente de un montón de
moléculas de gas ni del mismo gas
y ahí estaban un montón de moléculas los
voy a pintar así muchos muchos muchos
muchos muchos de los que he dibujado por
eso se van a mover al azar digamos en
todas las direcciones es de lo mejor
puede ir muy rápido hacia acá está un
poquito más lento este en esta otra
dirección todos tienen sus vectores
velocidad verdad y están constantemente
rebotando entre ellos ok y chocando y
cambiando la velocidad en general
especialmente en este nivel de la física
suponemos que este es un gas ideal no es
decir que todos los choques todos los
choques son que ocurren son sin pérdida
de energía esencialmente son choques
elásticos de verdad entre las diferentes
moléculas no hay pérdida del momento
tengamos eso en mente y todo lo que
vamos a ver desde la prepa o bueno todo
lo que se ve en prepa son gases ideales
así que vamos a pensar en la presión en
este contexto así que bueno todo lo que
sabemos sobre la presión es digamos una
fuerza que se imprime sobre una área no
y si pensamos en la presión en esta en
esta cara déjeme déjenme tomar esta en
este lado esta superficie del contenedor
cuál es cuál es la presión que va a ser
generada en esta superficie va a ser
generada por justo las millones y
billones y trillones de pequeños choques
cada vez verdad en cada momento déjenme
déjenme poner este es el lado digamos
este es el lado del contenedor cada
segundo hay un montón de estas pequeñas
moléculas de gas que se están moviendo
por ahí y si tomamos un arbitrario
periodo de tiempo siempre van a estar
rebotando en este lado verdad entonces
digamos que estamos buscando un tiempo
en una en una super pequeña fracción de
tiempo y en cada período de tiempo estos
están aquí chocando o a lo mejor estos
están rebotando sé de esta forma este
cambio de momento y se va a justo así
esto puede haber rebotado así quién sabe
lo que está pasando es que en cualquier
momento como hay tantas moléculas
siempre va a haber
siempre va a haber algunas moléculas que
están chocando en este en este lado de
la pared verdad cuando cuando chocan
tienen un cambio de momento entonces de
hecho la fuerza es el cambio
cambio en el momento
/ el cambio en el tiempo lo que estoy
diciendo es que en un intervalo de
tiempo en algún periodo de ese tiempo un
montón de partículas están cambiando su
momento en la en este lado del mundo
verdad
así que eso es lo que está generando una
fuerza y si pensamos en cómo podemos
promediar esto porque es bastante
difícil seguirle el paso a cada
partícula individualmente y cuando
hacemos estado de cinemática y demás
bueno estamos realmente lidiando con un
gas verdad y esto en un nivel macro no
puedes llevar una noción de todo lo que
está pasando con cada una de las
moléculas de hecho podemos decir que en
promedio estas muchas partículas están
cambiando su momento en esta pared así
que la fuerza ejercida en esta pared de
la de esta superficie va a ser x lo que
sea lo que sabemos es que la fuerza es
cuando conocemos el área de esta pared
podemos decir que la presión es igual a
la fuerza entre el área verdad de ahí
podemos despejar la fuerza pero bueno
esto de qué nos sirve como nos ayuda a
esto
quería darles primero un poco de
intuición para que vean cómo cómo se da
realmente está este tipo de fórmulas que
realmente necesitas conocer en
termodinámica y así como vamos a ir en
los siguientes vídeos espero probarles
porque esto funciona y no solo es
intuición ahora ahora entiendes cuál es
el contexto de un gas en un contenedor
verdad con esto fuera del camino déjenme
darles una fórmula
y espero que al final de este vídeo ya
tengan intuición de por qué esta fórmula
funciona en general si tenemos un gas
ideal en un contenedor tenemos que la
presión ejercida en el gas del gas o en
el lado del contenedor o de hecho en
cualquier punto del gas no este derecho
todo se vuelve homogéneo verdad ya
hablaremos dentro bien en futuros vídeos
pero bueno en su superficie
tenemos que la presión por el volumen es
igual a una constante
ok veremos en vídeos futuros que este es
proporcional al promedio de la energía
cinética de las moléculas que están
rebotando si las moléculas se están
moviendo mucho más rápido entonces vas a
tener más energía cinética y va a estar
cambiando más el momento en los lados y
entonces tendrías mayor presión ahora
vamos a ver si podemos dar más intuición
de por qué la presión por la témpera
perdón por el volumen es de esta forma
de gm
ok
con otro color digamos que aquí tengo un
montón de
de moléculas de un gas en este
contenedor
un montón y justo como les mostré
anteriormente en todo lo que borre estos
están rebotando por todos lados a cierta
nose cierta velocidad no sé
en cada una de las moléculas puede tener
distinta energía pero bueno como se
están transfiriendo momento las zonas o
las otras en promedio podemos hablar de
que tienen una energía cinética dada no
porque se mantienen rebotando y chocando
con las con los muros de este contenedor
ahora qué pasa si pudiera yo apachurrar
la cajita y
y algo más chico el volumen de esta caja
digamos que ahora ya tengo esta cajita
así apachurrada ahí tengo tengo esta
misma caja con el mismo gas pero ya lo
hice más pequeño así que hice más
pequeño el volumen que es lo que va a
suceder bueno tengo el mismo número de
moléculas aquí ok el mismo número de
moléculas con la misma energía cinética
en y en promedio están moviéndose a la
misma velocidad así que qué es lo que va
a ocurrir
van a estar golpeando los lados con
mayor frecuencia verdad porque aquí
bueno aquí por ejemplo choca en un lado
y en lo que rebota y choca lo otro bueno
esto en el lado en la cajita más pequeña
es más más rápido verdad tienen un
cambio de momento más rápido así que vas
a tener que cada partícula está
ejerciendo más fuerza en cada una de las
superficies porque va a estar
golpeándolo con mayor frecuencia en el
tiempo verdad así que tienes más fuerza
en la superficie y vamos a tener por
consecuencia mayor presión así que
espero que esto les haya dado intuición
de qué pasa con la presión
en esta situación si yo apachurra el
volumen entonces la presión aumenta otra
otra idea por ejemplo para pensar es qué
pasa con un globo bueno el aire interno
con el que lo llenas digamos helio o
cuando tú exhalas digamos dentro del
globo este mientras mas trátase
apachurrar el globo
ok tienes que a para curarlo en todas
las direcciones verdad esto es más
difícil de hacer porque hay cada vez
mayor presión que en que imprime el gas
en en las paredes del globo entonces si
el volumen baja entonces la presión
aumenta y eso tiene sentido verdad esto
se sigue cuando multiplicas ambos y
tiene que ser la misma constante bueno
de ahí se sigue no entonces qué pasa si
el volumen lo haces más grande digamos
que hago esto mucho más grande bueno
esto debió haber sido proporcional a la
figura inicial pero espero que entiendan
la idea entonces tienen un mayor número
de partículas y si tuviera una partícula
aquí digamos en cierto periodo de tiempo
está chocando para
entonces está chocando en las paredes
varias veces en esta situación le toma
mayor tiempo chocar e ir hasta el otro
lado de hasta el otro muro así que las
partículas en promedio van a estar
colisionando con menor frecuencia y las
paredes buenos ejercerá menor fuerza
sobre el área verdad de la de las
paredes así que si el volumen aumenta en
este caso la presión del contenedor baja
espero que esto les dé un poquito de
intuición y así no se les olvide lo que
la presión por la por el volumen es una
constante verdad después usaremos esto
en próximos vídeos porque se me está
acabando el tiempo